[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i came across this video and i found it
very profound and i wanted to share it
with you guys
this specific show is about nurturing
one another learning from
current affairs things are happening
around the world and what we can derive
from them
this was very profound this is a young
kid in the audience asking habib
can you tell me about your mom how is
she living let's see how khabib answers
inshallah and what we can learn from
[Music]
this
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
okay guys so you can see from that you
know he's um
obviously with his boxing career we know
it's haram he himself knows it's haram
it's not permissible
but his how he is with his mom and we
can see in general his
discipline his principles you know there
is a another video that i saw of his
where he was saying he was making dua
that may allah always keep our elders
there in our lives and you can see that
the manners that he has towards his
eldest which is something that we have
lost today
forget our elders we have lost it to our
parents
our mother and father there are people
out there that abuse
their mothers and their fathers yeah
your mom and dad wants the best for you
and it reminds me of a story of abdullah
bin umar
and once he saw a man from yemen coming
to do tawaf
and he was carrying his mom on his
shoulders and as he was walked doing
tawaf around
for her with her he was saying i am my
mother's
humble i am a mother's humble camel he
was keep saying that and after done
he came to abdullah and he said oh
abdullah
yeah i mean he said
he said he said have i repaid my mum
back for what she has done for me
i said you have not paid her back
for one off she said when she gave birth
to you
one off that she said that little one
contraction that she had
when she gave birth to you this is the
rights of our mothers
it's the rights of our mothers and this
is very very key and fundamental
very fundamental that when we are
looking for a spouse
do not forget the responsibility that
it's the amount of the rights that your
kids have is
number one the mother that you're gonna
choose for them
and the father is well don't get it
twisted the father you're gonna choose
for them in the marriage process
these are their rights if you pick the
wrong mother for them
it's gonna be on your case so it's very
important for you to look for that
the future mother for your children or
the future father to your children and
look at the relationship with the person
that you want to marry
how it how is it with their parents if
you see a problem with the parents
somebody that does not give the rights
of the one who gave
birth to them will never ever give you
your right as a wife
or a husband and this is very important
now i'm not saying obviously there's
some people whose parents
mom and dad are wrong and oppressed them
but in no way shape does that give a
right to anybody to raise their hand out
of the bill to their parents
raise their voice to their parents allah
says in the quran
that after i have ordered you to worship
me obey the parents
muslim or not muslim brothers and
sisters
i think we learn a beautiful lesson from
khabib once again like i said before
good character may allah
see that within him and implement in our
lives to our parents because once our
parents are gone
they're gone you can never replace your
mum and dad never
until next time brother sisters from
current affairs that we're
covering on this channel and do not
forget to check brother smiles agendas
channel he's doing amazing
with current effects as well funny
videos that i personally love watching
and i'm subscribed
subscribe to him inshaallah and myself
inshallah and if you want the base and
discussions mahmoud
channel that's it take care assalamu
assalamualaikum